the Today's Show has a report
about the hot new consumer product on
the market that uh everybody is raving
about apparently this this is
all completely news to me I'm not even
pretending to be out of the loop to be
cool or something I really didn't even
know I I I didn't know that this was a
thing apparently it's a thing there's a
cup um a new cup actually it's not a new
cup it's a cup brand that's been around
for 100 years but
recently people are very very uh
determined to get their hands on this
particular cup here's the Today's Show
with the
report the hot gift drawing screams and
sobs of Joy oh she wanted
a and all this hysteria over a cup I got
a
Stanley the Stanley quencher Cup that is
sold in over a hundred different colors
the $45 reusable bottles are flying off
shelves the # Stanley Cup racking up 6.7
billion ion views on Tik Tok with videos
of fans collecting them decorating them
naming them even camping out for them so
it's almost 3:00 in the morning people
lining up overnight at Starbucks and
Target stores to snag a limited edition
version I don't find it blue Aaliyah and
Sarai Di's cups runneth over after
unwrapping theirs on Christmas morning
why are you so obsessed with these cups
so everyone in school basically has them
usually I don't drink a lot of water but
like when I have this cup I drink like
more water believe it or not the Stanley
brand has been around for more than a
century these cups used to be favored
among construction workers but in 2017
after a popular mommy blog posted about
them the company introduced new pastel
colors and sales skyrocketed from 73
million in 2019 to 750 Million last year
Stanley CEO spoke to cnbc's make it so
it was a slow build over many months and
then you could see that the waiting
lists began to grow adding to the hype
viral videos of the Cup's apparent
indestructibility like this one that
survived a
carire well that's good I mean it's
important to have a cup that can survive
a carfire i you yourself probably won't
survive the carfire but at least your
cup will be okay and that's all that
matters your cup will survive your cup
will live on to tell your story Through
the Ages I guess so this is the New
Sensation it's an insulated cup
um Ian that's all it is it's an insul
there are millions of insulated cups on
the market they're all the same the
Stanley Cup is not functionally
different from any other insulated cup
but this is the one that everybody wants
right now and why do they want it uh
they don't know they they they couldn't
tell you um but they'll camp out
overnight for it they'll camp out
overnight for a
cup and they want it because everyone
else has it which which which by the way
from from a a child as we saw in the
Today Show report you know asking
children why they want the C for a child
to say oh I want it because all my
friends have it like that is
understandable from a child now what I
don't understand first of all is like
how what's the background I always want
to know what's what's going on behind
the what's the behind the scenes story
for how those two random uh little girls
ended up on the Today Show to talk about
their cups like I I assume Today's Show
Producer would have had to contact those
girls
mother and say oh we can we have your
kids on the show to talk about their
cups um so I don't and I don't know why
you'd agree to that as a parent but in
any in any event uh it's one thing for
children there another thing for adults
but this is what they're doing and
they're waiting in long lines for it uh
and there there are there are a lot of
videos like this so here's one of a very
long line of of people at
Target waiting for apparently it's a
specifically a pink Stanley Cup they all
want a a pink cup is the is the one that
everyone wants the most even guys even
even even men want the pink cup and then
an argument breaks out when a group of
young guys who again for some reason
want a pink cup uh and they cut in line
and it starts an argument and let's
watch
this you're like you yeah okay keep
talking this going to go Mega viral I'm
so these two got these three cut and lie
behind the rest of these people who are
all here waiting so I'm just going to
protect the collectors and the people
who rightfully get here
bye
so line etiquette if you what it doesn't
matter she's going to bring out the
video proof and that's what's going to
go on matter that my body that it
doesn't matter to me it doesn't matter
to me I'm just here to advocate for the
people who are waiting you can tell me
anything you want well it's good we have
a line judge here no I'm not a line
judge I'm just I'm just a decent human
being I'm a decent human being who
waited and I no I heard this scal behind
you wait a long time and she was
unhappy if you guys want to watch this
jokester on live Ray is sunshine on Tik
Tok uh I hate everything about this this
is everything I hate
altogether you got a bunch of
mindless morons waiting in line for some
consumer product they're at
Target you got guy cutting in line
you've got a woman taking a video
bragging that it's going to go Mega
viral everything now normally I would
say that line Cutters are the scum of
the earth and deserve to have their
voting rights taken away except in thisa
which they do but in this case everyone
in that line should have their voting
rights taken away now I know that I I
say this about a lot of different people
that should have their voting rights
because there are a lot of people should
vote there should only be like five
people in this country that have the
right to vote at this point um but but
at least we could start here like if I
was in charge I would just show up
anywhere they're selling a Stanley Cup
anybody in line i' say okay what's your
name you can't vote anymore you're done
you're banished for you never you're
never allowed to vote again for the rest
of your life because you're wait like
maybe if there are two people like if
you're waiting in line and there's two
people and you're waiting in a line
that's three people
long I could accept that but you go to
the end of that line like how do you you
walk in and you see that line how do you
not just immediately turn around oh the
line's this long for a cup I'm not gonna
wait this
line and then how you say to yourself
okay you know what I I'll do this this
will be this will be my day I'll spend
my day doing this put some prep in your
step with good ranchers new year new
meat special delicious safe and
convenient me meal prep is just one box
away 2024 is your year to ditch the
mystery of the meat aisle and get
American Meat delivered right to your
door instead when you subscribe to any
box of good ranchers they'll add over 2
lbs of pre-trimmed better than organic
chicken breast to your order for free
not once not twice but every order for
an entire year good ranchers chicken
will change what you know about chicken
it's pasture raised given zero
antibiotics or vaccines it's so tender
juicy you won't believe it's the same
meat you've been eating most of your
life stock your fridge with easy to
prepare clean delicious meat all year
long not sure which box to choose we'll
try their brand new weekly Essentials
box full of pre-trimmed beef and chicken
as well that helps you a meal prep so
you can save time without sacrificing
flavor go to goodranchers.com use my
code Walsh to enjoy free chicken in 2024
plus an additional $2 off your first
order change the way that you buy meat
by switching to good ranchers subscribe
today and use my code walls to claim
over $200 in free chicken and New Year
savings goodranchers.com American Meat
delivered and those Cups by the way all
like 50 bucks I looked it up unless you
get them on the secondary market for
$10,000 so we've got inflation we have
people that are having trouble making
ends
meet uh the economy's in the
toilet and yet people are also spending
50 bucks a pop on a trendy
Cup and the thing is if you were to ask
any of the people standing in that line
you look at all the dead eyed and dazed
people in any of these lines waiting for
the Stanley Cup none of them would be
able to explain why they want that
particular cup if you went up to them
and said what are you waiting in this
line for oh I want the Stanley Cup why
that cup what do you need that cup for
uh I don't know it's a cup they they
don't even seem excited about the cup
they're not standing there with wild
anticipation for their treasured
cup they're just there it's almost
businesslike as if they're required by
law it's like you you'd think that was
align at the DMV you think that people
are required to be there by law but
they're not they've decided to spend
their day doing this for a
cup what would a Stanley Cup fan say if
I were to because this is a cup that has
fans if I asked them to explain their
Fascination what would they say well I
like it because it can hold liquids and
it can keep my coffee hot yes and and
you can go to Walmart and find literally
hundreds of cups that perform both of
those functions just as well in fact the
first function of holding liquids I got
news for
you every Cup on Earth can do that find
any cup at all and it can hold your
liquids or it's not a cup by definition
and as far as keeping it warm or cold
that that's an insulated cup and uh and
any cup could look I know this is
nothing new these pointless Trends and
consumer obsessions uh I live through
the beanie Bay Praise of the '90s okay
so uh I know all about it but it is uh
it is it's just pathetic even so a cup
is a cup so get over
it that is unless it's a leftist tears
tumbler or a sweet baby gang insulated
mug now these are real high quality cups
now these are cups that you should pay a
premium for and you will if you go to
dailywire.com shop which you should
right now thanks for check out this
video if you'd like to listen to my full
podcast on the go you can check out the
Matt wall show on Apple podcast Spotify
or wherever you get your podcasts